the other team is telling us with all  these set plays maybe we should copy  what they do let's run the triangle  office I heard about that on TV how do  they win James with this in the 90s he's  a big man in the polls amplifier nice  lady I can't jump supplant  the Flex offense that's the ticket okay  play like that  we gotta improvise we got to make our  own music you got to play this like Jay  yes I think I heard that in the elevator  once no no would you gotta go plate slap  shot no kicks and poles how about a fast  rate playing again he met a pig just  like at a straight crossing a paternity  community knew the game juvenile like  two children walking clean ball with the  shoulder names pull to the hole with a  gun you know that is a word we turn now  1-0  hasta la Bamba